going back again to 5150 I'm talking
about Best of Both Worlds which is a
great song what were you
thinking about were you thinking about
uh i' I've got Van Halen and I've got
what were the Best of Both Worlds I was
thinking about reincarnation and about
you know about heaven about dying and
going to heaven people you know everyone
talks about how beautiful Heaven is and
and everything and I was thinking about
you know love I'm a I'm a lover man I
want to be in love that's all I want
just keep me in love and I'm the
happiest guy in the world I don't need
anything else when you're in love like
CU you got heaven right here on Earth
man we can do it baby and and I just
felt it I I don't know like I say I'm
sitting here with the Goosebumps
and what do you do now you got now you
got the lyrics in your head you go to
the band and you guys get in a room and
you what you start you belt it out yeah
the band had already recorded it kind of
they had already learned it and not
recorded we they were rehearsing some
demos of it and I was scatting along to
it I was doing I
know
you know I was doing that and I record
it too on that cassette and then I would
take it home and listen to what I was
singing and I Tred to write lyrics to it
and I don't know what I've been living
on but it's not enough to fill me up I
need more than just words can say I need
everything that's life can give me hey
hey you know I need the best of both
World heaven right here on Earth come on
man Michael when you hear when you hear
when you hear Sam Michael when you hear
Sammy coming in with those lyrics um you
start writing in your head where to come
in and double his voice uh yeah I mean I
I'll come in and I'll start harmonizing
with him anywhere that I think it might
fit and then I just kind of you know
weed it out a bit and and just kind of
work it out like that boys take us back
to that time let's go back come
onck the
[Music]
damn
funky
I don't know what I've been living on
but it's not enough to fild me
up I need more than just words to
say I need everything life can give me
hey
hey sometimes it's not
enough I say come on baby close your
eyes let go down this can be everything
we
dream it's not work that makes it work
oh no just let the magic do the work for
you cuz honey something reached out and
touch me now I know all I want I want
the CU baby I know what it's worth if we
could have the best
little bit of heaven right here on
[Music]
Earth woo now there's a picture in a
gallery this this falling angel look
just like
you weget where we come from sometimes
but I I had a dream it was really
you something reached out and touched me
now I know that all I want I want the
best
of and baby I know what it's worth if we
could have the best of the world little
been a heaven right here on Earth
[Music]
woo
[Applause]
this where you get the audience clapping
come on everybody put your hands
[Music]
in you don't have to die and go to
heaven or hang around to be born
again just tune in to what this place
has got to offer we may never be here
again I want the
[Music]
best I know what it's
worth I need the
best little bit of heav right here on
Earth now come on I need the best of
baby baby baby baby I need the
best heaven right here on
Earth
yeah sometimes it's not
enough now will it ever be
[Music]
enough
[Applause]
[Music]
wow
yeah damn oh such a good song and it
it's great to see you I love watch I
might actually have to go to this show
you're going to do you know I
show up mandat mandatory this is
fantastic